I'd like to think of us as the 21st
century blacksmiths you know blacksmiths
made tools and those tools enable two
other people to do fantastically
important work and we are tool makers
here our time is a platform for taking
massive amounts of data synthesizing it
and displaying it in different ways so
people can explore and learn and find
new insights into what's happening in
the world today we want people to
understand how the earth is changing
around us and the degree to which our
actions affect our children's future at
the same time we want people to
understand the demography of the earth
how politics how sociology how disease
are changing the way we live as we
address these global issues we need to
be able to start from a common set of
understanding the polarization today
often comes from people starting from
different facts and we need we need to
be able to fix that and if we do that in
a way that's so unbiased so neutral that
it actually charts common ground between
all the different peoples on earth so
that whatever your political leanings
may be you see this as a truth that lets
you have common semantics and common
discourse so the last picture I want to
show you is an extraordinary image of
refugees across the world the reactions
that we get when we show earth time are
diverse but they're really powerfully
emotionally we've had cases where people
will run up to the stage and the
interactive tablet that we have and ask
us to zoom in on a particular place when
we're showing for instance sea level
rise and we zoom in and we zoom in and
they say oh my god that's my house my
house is gonna go underwater because of
this and then they jump up and they want
to talk policy and what's happened is
we've taken the story and made it so
intimately personal that now they are
driven in every way to make a difference
[Music]